>> I BELIEVE YOU CAN CONVINCE
YOURSELF OF ANYTHING.
>> Tucker: NICELY PUT AND TRUE.
INVESTIGATION FOUND LITTLE
EVIDENCE OF THE RUSSIAN
AND SOME OF DONALD TRUMP'S
CAMPAIGN ARE CONSIDERING A
LAWSUIT.
>> Tucker: THE OBVIOUS QUESTION,
SERVING IN THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN,
>> NO, I DID NOT.
WHAT I TOLD THE HOUSE
INTELLIGENCE COMMITTEE IN JULY:
I SAW NO RUSSIAN COLUKAS.
-- LUKAS.
-- COLLUSION.
I HEARD NO TALK OF RUSSIA.
WE DID NOT USE RUSSIAN DRESSING.
THIS IS A BOGUS INVESTIGATION
BECAUSE HILLARY CLINTON NEEDS AN
MY FAMILY GETS TO PAY FOR IT.
>> Tucker: HOW MUCH HAVE HAD YOU
TO PAY PERSONALLY TO RESPOND TO
THIS?
>> SENATE INTELLIGENCE WANTS ME
FOR TWO YEARS.
AND DIANE FEINSTEIN WANTS HE.
-- ME.
EACH HEARING IS $30,000.
>> Tucker: THAT'S HORRIFYING.
>> IT IS HORRIFYING.
I HAVE KIDS TO RAISE.
I LIVE IN FLY OVER COUNTRY.
I LIVE IN BUFFALO.
THIS SMEAR FIRST AND ASK
BUT A LOT OF FAMILIES.
>> Tucker: ON TOTALLY RIDICULOUS
GROUNDS OF RUSSIAN AGENTS.
THAT'S ABSURD.
APPARENTLY THE MEMO SAYS THAT
THE OBAMA ADMINISTRATION USED
OF THE TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
>> I LISTENED TO WHAT YOU SAID
LEADING UP TO THIS SEGMENT.
I AM DISGUSTED BUT I EXPECTED
IT.
THANK GOD FOR CHAIRMAN MAN
NUNES.
HE'S ENDURED SO MUCH INSULTS
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE AND
POLITIZED THE FBI.
I KNOW A LOT OF RANK-AND-FILE
FBI MEMBERS.
THEY ARE ALL EMBARRASSED ABOUT
THIS.
THE DOJ WEAPONIZED.
DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE WENT AFTER
CONGRESS AND MICHAEL GRIMM AND
MANY OTHERS.
IT'S ON ITS WAY TO HAPPENING FOR
QUITE SOMETIME.
WE ARE AT THE MOST POLITICIZED
LEVEL OF OUR DOJ AND FBI IN MY
LIFETIME.
>> Tucker: IT SURE SEEMS THAT
WAY.
I DON'T KNOW IF YOU RESPOND TO
THIS FINAL QUESTION BECAUSE YOU
ARE THE SUBJECT OF A LOT OF
ATTENTION.
CARTER PAGE WAS THE PRETEXT FOR
A LOT OF THIS SPYING ON THE
TRUMP CAMPAIGN.
I ONLY SAW HIM DURING MSNBC
INTERVIEWS.
HE DOESN'T LOOK LIKE A CREDIBLE
RUSSIAN AGENT.
DID YOU SEE ANY INICATION HE WAS
SPEAKING TO THE RUSSIANS?
ANYTHING THAT MADE YOU THINK HE
IN TRUMP TOWER.
HE WAS LIKE PAPADOPOULOS.
VOLUNTEERS WHO WOULD COME IN FOR
ONE MEETING A MONTH.
CARTER PAGE, HE IS LEGIT.
KNOWS ABOUT RUSSIA AND PEOPLE IN
RUSSIA KNOW HIM.
HE WAS IN BUSINESS THERE.
I SEE HIM IN TELEVISION.
FIRST I WOULD PALMS UP ABOUT THE
GUY.
NOW I FEEL BAD FOR HIM.
I HEAR ABOUT THIS MEMO AND I
FEEL ANGRY FOR HIM.
>> Tucker: HE SAID TODAY TO A
PRODUCER AT FOX NEWS THAT HE
WILLIAMS  -- WELCOMES THE